[Music]
all right time to check back with ted
lorendo we talked about the wind but i
think the biggest headline here
is the heat yeah the temperatures that
we have not seen since early october
christian so yeah
we're going to heat up real quick here
we're going to show you those numbers in
just a bit another live look outside
from far west side of the valley
this is our red rock station casino
tower cam i like this because
i can really see those winds blowing
outside you can see the palm tree
look how clear it is too moderate air
quality as well because we have a little
bit of dust
that's being kicked up with these winds
olive grasses ragweed all reporting
moderate to high readings right now and
that's why
we did that story on the allergies
because a lot of people are suffering
i'm with you there too 82 degrees
for sky canyon right now along with
centennia hill 79 for aliante 84 for
north las vegas these are your current
temperatures
outside at this four o'clock hour 81 for
sunrise manor
80 whitney ranch 82 for henderson
mountains edge and in sprout at 76.
right now we're in the high 70s for
spring valley and also out there in
also out there in summerlin 79 for
anthem at this hour 81 currently for
prompt 79 boulder city
86 right now those of you in laughlin
and death valley are warming up to 91
degrees
we had a few of those spots of showers
around the region yesterday
that's now pivoting off towards the east
where you can still see some showers
just south of flagstaff
and eastern arizona as that low
continues to move off towards the east
now what we're seeing
way out in the ocean is high pressure so
you got the low here
you've got the high here we've got what
we call a titan pressure gradient
between the two anytime you have those
near each other you're going to get
those strong winds and that's why we
have those big gusts
for the day today we'll continue to see
those for the next few hours here as you
can see in our wind forecast
anytime you see these big colors out
about here that means it is windy too
breezy now these colors go away
that's later on tonight so those winds
will decrease more
and then tomorrow i think will be
lighter winds tomorrow although some
neighborhoods to the north will still
see some breezes
but the stronger winds return again on
saturday so
speaking of saturday here's your weekend
forecast the reason i'm showing you this
is because we'll be approaching record
highs again on friday and saturday at
102's our record
will be at 97 for saturday that's what
we're calling for right now that could
change
and the record is best set back in 1947
now
sunday will cool things off so we'll
drop those numbers
as another system rolls through however
both days
are going to see some wind so just get
used to it's the time of year we get
those
spring winds 62 degrees overnight clear
and cool
breezy at times tomorrow even warmer
north breezes will still be around in
some neighborhoods
remember 82s are normal for this time of
year we're going to be above that
many of our neighborhoods in the high
80s some of you touch in the 90s like
sunrise manor
green valley possibly henderson nellis
90 outside of town we'll be at 86. you
know we'll be
at triple digits for death valley if
we're going to be close to 90 tomorrow
death valley 103 tomorrow laughlin at
98. here's your eight on the eight fork
everybody sign
in the studio when they see those
numbers it's not gonna last though okay
because here's what's gonna happen like
we said we'll get near record territory
friday and saturday
numbers drop 86 on monday good to see
that
however remember we're getting to may so
those numbers go right back up
so a week from today we'll be right back
up to the high 90s again
it's just that time of the year that's
your most accurate forecast here on
eight news now brian loftus mr loftis is
standing by
in our a news now newsroom to show us
what they're cooking up at five brian
over to you